the thing that made fanatic so great in
CS go is they were just soing toxic I
know it seems kind of cringe by modern
standards but they were basically like
the bad boys of csgo even like the
burning defus like this was just like
you know it's a whatever play but like
the little the little dance at the end
right like this is like it's kind it's
kind of BM this is probably the most
famous example of this so this is JW
being uh fast cat right gets up here
with the op some nice movement right
heing hops on to Short and just rinses
going to go on a mission he's desperate
to show that this is a viable choice I
know he does I know he does it's one of
my favorite C calls so kjun goes for the
peak long right gets the peak they Molly
it off JW pushes his own Molly and gets
the the pick top me they were
just toxic man everybody fuing hated
them they just did the stupidest
and it works they were they were just so
much better I actually missed the team
immensely they were so fun to watch